it's a fascinating and incredibly
dangerous poker game
between vladimir putin and alexei
navalny
the odds are against navalny inside
russia inside a prison right now
is the future of russia the russian soul
at its best
the most interesting place to be right
now is in prison with alexey navalny
alexey navani is a guy who's been
poisoned
imprisoned multiple times had acid and
green paint thrown on him
called vladimir putin a poison toad and
flown drones over his mansion on youtube
and somehow not died this
reads sounds like a spy novel
it's actually um i'm thinking of um
a poem um
by le montov a hero
of our time actually it's a novel um i
don't
whenever i get into this i want to drink
vodka and annoyingly
i'm on gin but he
is a hero of our time alexei navalny and
i've met him
twice and i the first time i properly
engaged with him was in 2016
and this guy is challenging
the kremlin in a way which is
extraordinarily brave chris
and and and people who say you know
what's he doing
you know he's been poisoned why on earth
is he going back to russia
people who who asked who say that
haven't been paying attention
i in very simple terms i met
um i've been going to russia since 92
i did russian o level at school i scrape
through it i don't speak russian but i
love it i love the culture
and when i used to work for the bbc i
would go there
every two years do something that would
annoy the kremlin
they would follow us around and then i'd
leave and the last time
i did a film called taking on putin and
i
and i met navalny for that twice and he
really is a hero
but um but here's the background
is that i met three russians who were
all critical of putin
at a time when the west was still trying
to rub along with putin one of them
um was annapolitive skyer the second
natasha estimarova
um they were both great journalists and
the third was boris nemtsov he was a
journalist and a politician
shot shot shot
so these three people who had the balls
to stand up to putin and to be critical
of them were all shot dead
and navalny knows this he knows the
history
and basically he's been challenging
putin's you know
the poison toads lock on power
lock on the kremlin for the past decade
and he knows that if you do that you may
well die
um the backlog doesn't look very good
for him does it
no um but he's doing it because i think
it's perfectly possible for him to live
a life in exile in germany or the states
or here
and then for one day cement mixer to
sort of cross over the road and knock
him out
um that isn't
so what he's doing is i mean i think you
know why the timing i
thought the timing was absolutely
amazing because what he's done is he's
got himself locked up
on the day that um that donald trump who
was
far too uncritical of vladimir putin has
gone
and joe biden is is now in place
and and then the moment he's locked up
up pops the video
and the video is about vladimir putin's
fancy new palace
it's a billion pound house
and it's disgusting you know
the detail i tweeted was that there was
a there's some kind of hooker bar
hooker h-o-k-a-h
but also e-r um
you would imagine and i say that with a
with a fair bit of evidence because this
is a stripper's pole
in it now it's
the other thing is if you go to russia
so i did a film
whenever it was 2005-64
the bbc about about vodka poisonings
what happened was that putin
hiked up the price of vodka and
um threefold putting it out of
out of reach of a lot of ordinary
russians who were very very poor
and the mafia moved in and started
flogging
um hand sanitizer alcohol-based
and basically you have to put in a
colorant
nobody cares people with alcohol
problems didn't care
and this caused an epidemic of liver
disease and people turned yellow
and i went into the hospitals and the
sticks and
god it was bleak so what you've got to
realize is that russia
is far crueler and
far more unfair and wealth is divided
far more unequally than anywhere in in
western europe or all those states
unfair as the state says so that the
idea that
you know there um there are ordinary
people
really suffer in russia but the idea
that the
what navalny calls the czar of
corruption
has built himself a new mansion a new
palace
is disgraceful so it's a fascinating and
incredibly dangerous poker game
between vladimir putin
and alexei navalny and
you know the poison toad and the kremlin
he's got the killing machine machinery
the fsb
which is the new name for the kgb he's
got
his lock on this monstrous corruption
engine the russian economy
and he's got the oligarchs and
navalny's in prison uh he's in roman
prison at the moment
facing trial he get locked up again so
the
odds are really really against him
however putin has been in power for
20 years and good russians i mean there
are
there's a new generation of russians
who've only known putin in power
who are now 20 who've got the vote
who've got
energy they've got belief and
at some point the poison toad
is gonna um is gonna run out of
um of supporters of money of people
willing to do the killing
so it's a the bet's
very much you know it's not a the odds
are against it but my money isn't on the
poison toad my money's on the value
how would you define navalny's political
approach his stance and
why is he important why is he popular
he's enormously charismatic i mean
you're a bit charismatic i can shout
he'd knock us dead uh he's got kind of
intense blue eyes
the only person actually there are three
there are two other people i'm thinking
about
who i've met in my time one of them is
the dalai lama the god king of tibet
who by the way has got a fantastic laugh
like um
sid james when barbara windsor used to
pop her bra
and he so that's the dalai lama but he
he's got a real commanding presence in a
beautiful way
the other person is bill clinton when he
walks into a room
bill clinton can command a room the
third person is alexei navalny so he's
got a real commanding presence
he's also he's got a wit
um if you watch the video which is how
many people have seen it now
26 million people have watched
the youtube video he put up last night
so we're recording this
on wednesday the 20th of january last
night
on the 19th he puts this two hour long
video up so it's not like something that
feeds the algorithm to go viral it's not
just a short little clip it's a
full-blown documentary and um you're
totally right like the level of
the level of charisma that he's got i i
can't work i almost want to
choke it up to the translations the
captions because i'm like you can't
speak this precisely
with this much wit just on command it
must be the the
closed captions making him look cool
he's
so he's got charm he's got fire he's got
wits
and it's for real um
um i mean 20 i've done a podcast called
hunting julem which i've just heard it's
it's now hit two million um downloads
link
in show notes below go and listen to it
it was awesome blah blah blah
this bastard uh let's say it's got
13 times as many hits as that i've got
two million
and and my stuff in a day [ __ ] off sorry
can we swear
away mate yeah you're on the gym
but he um and he was
really funny really intense and and
sticking it
sticking it to the russian the then
russian prosecutor general uh jaika
saying all concerned deny any wrongdoing
but putting out the evidence
that the um the prosecutor general
and his family had benefited
um from uh corruption and
the the victim of the corruption who
complained ended up dead
so navalny has been doing this you know
to my personal knowledge
um from 2016
but actually he's been doing before that
and and
there's almost something monkish
in the sense of there's a religious
fervor
that he's bringing this war against
corruption so
navalny is a dissenter he appears to not
really care about
the powers that be and he's just happy
to continue on his path
i like how you said that he seems almost
monkish he's got this kind of religious
fervor behind him
that's compelling him but really all
that is is just values and
integrity in a place where there isn't
much
and many of your listeners might start
falling
off their chairs but they're going to
say it
he's a lawyer and he believes
in the truth of the law um
and he kind of reminds me of sir thomas
more
in the bitten man for all seasons i love
robert bolt who wrote that
who was just a fantastic um
writer and there's a bid in um
in um thomas more uh mandeville seasons
where richard rich says oh you know it's
unparaphrasing screw the law doesn't
matter
and and thomas more says no you're wrong
because the law is the law
of england or england is planted thick
with laws
and they're there to protect us and if
we knock them down the devil can come
for us
that's what the law is for and so what
navalny does very
cleverly both in his videos and in his
defenses he says no that's
that's unlawful and he uses the
information
that's available uh to him to
to nail putin's illegality
again and again and again and anybody
who knows russia
knows how crooked the regime is and how
crooked the russian state is
the soviet union was crooked too
but it had some sense
of equality i'm a little bit so bit
nostalgic
in relation to them to the late
to the late 70s because there was so
much hope then
i i wasn't old enough to properly
understand this but i've heard this from
from um older russians but they had some
hope that what replaced
um the nonsense the great big live
soviet communism would be better
and it's turned out that yes
economic life has been better but
actually in reality
uh political life is is somehow
darker because there's no hope and it's
more joyless
i make a distinction i've written a
novel called
um the useful idiot which is about
stalin's
time about fake news in 1933
and that's that time was really dark
and stalin looked good because hitler
was so
bad but stalin was bad too
and um and what's happened is that putin
putin is more of an heir to stalin than
people
think not for nothing the other day when
he was arrested
in the police station and there's a
trial taking place in the police station
on the wall there's a picture of this
man peria
lavrenti iberia beeria was stalin's
secret policeman
he was the mass murderer he killed
our occasion the death of millions of
people who
died in the gulag so
there's a continuity of darkness
of of evil empowered which
which certainly gorbachev and yeltsin
broke
both of those men were good men
wrestling with all the contradictions
of russian power um gorbachev
ineffectually yeltsin good to begin with
and then he drank himself into
into into being a useful gibberer
gibberish wasn't good enough
and the problem is there's this awful
dark moment of succession
when nobody quite knows who's going to
take over from yeltsin
and then this the poison tone toad putin
appears
and is navalny is navalny juxtaposing
his extreme integrity and extreme virtue
at least publicly to create a contrast
with putin is that part of his appeal do
you think
he always does it with a joke so the
downside
to navalny and some of my russian
friends
are worried about him if he does get
power is
that around about 2789
he he dallied with the russian
right the nationalist right now russia
is for a whole series of reasons
it is it a center of its politics
almost like 10 or 20 degrees to the
right than that
i was going to say the extreme right in
russia must be
really really right no they're nazis
and and and he wasn't one of them
but he was he said he used
language um in code but the code wasn't
very
wasn't very good which
was um talking about
effectively um the purity of russianness
uh about russian roots and
there's um and this was politics of the
other
and the other here being the mainly
muslim people from the south
um people like the chechens um
who who weren't um
who many russians don't see as russians
what happened was
navalny got locked up and going to
prison was the making of him because
he started doing well he became
too well he was too he was on telly and
people could see his charisma
and they switched off the telly and they
locked him up for a short while
but while he was locked up in prison he
he really got to know the liberal
opposition
and he listened to their arguments and
beliefs and
when he left prison he
he had absorbed the arguments and
beliefs
of the liberal opposition and allied
himself
with them again and again and again and
since then he has um dropped
the nationalists rhetoric and
you haven't heard that kind of language
from him for a decade
so i think he's through that point um
and
um and that's uh in the past
since then he's done two particular
things and that
he's i i forget the details of it but he
he's his family is mixed up russian
and ukrainian as many many russians and
ukrainians are
and he learns um to speak ukrainian he's
got obviously
had uh what has ukrainian gram grand
grandpa and grandma and loved them
opposed putin's war against ukraine
now that's big potatoes because the
russian right doesn't like that
and then the other thing is he has he's
the only
um serious figure in russian politics
who stands up the same sex relationships
same-sex marriages
then that's super non-right so the idea
which the kremlin put out but he's a
racist i don't think that's
that's true um and hasn't been true for
a decade
may not have been true back then but i'm
uneasy about the language he used
back then he doesn't use it anymore what
is what he's done
what are some of the wars that he's got
into over the last decade
because there's been his brother's in
jail in solitary confinement and then he
was getting locked up
himself every five days because he
didn't have a permit to
campaign and sum up with green paint and
then embezzling and all sorts
take us through some of those stories so
um
the by the way i'm a bit wired because
donald trump
has um has left and joe biden
has come and so you're hitting me with
asking me details so i'm apologizing uh
to your listeners
in that i can be better than this but
i'm too excited about what's happening
in america i'm also excited because of
this
queasy relationship between vladimir
putin
and donald trump that's over folks and
the valley knows it
that's why the timing so um
in a rough and ready way what happens is
that um
putin has been ineffective the boss of
russia for two decades
and that's against the constitution
because borrowing from the american
constitution
you can only do two terms i think four
years four years which got you to 2008
at that point it's arrivederci mr putin
you're out
what he does is he does a switch
with this guy called um um
i'm gonna what's his name dimitri
i'm the i've got the wrong name stuck in
my head but he's the
he becomes the president and putin is
the prime minister
the reality is all the power sticks
with putin um there's a
a wonderful um friend of mine who's
written this
great um book uh stalin and his hangman
um and i've gotten his name too but
never mind i'll it'll come back to me
memory pops up
in a wonderful way and he described
the president it's dmitry damn i keep on
wanting to say liberdade but it's not
lebadop dimitri
it means the bear in russian dmitry
the president described by my friend
um donald rayfield professor donald
rayfield author of stalinist hangman
as al capone's lawyer
so al capone's lawyer is the president
of russia
for four years until 2012 and then in
2012
guess what the constitution is rewritten
and vladimir putin pops back up again
this time running for president
he wins but the whole thing is
a joke it's a lie it's an undermining of
the
the true spirit of democracy and navalny
coming as he is from the right of
politics
allies with the liberals and there
they start a big series of
demonstrations a big in the two great
cities
saying petersburg and moscow but there
are
shadow demos across the country remember
it's huge nine times sense
and it's a big threat to putin's power
eventually what happens is the
demonstrations
die out um
people they can see that power isn't
shifting putin's there to stay
and also um once the
um the big noise on the streets is
quietened
then the regime starts locking people up
and one of the people they lock up
is of course navalny who gets locked up
inside where
and he gets to know people like boris
nemtsov nemtsov
is fantastically funny and um
would have been a wonderful president of
russia
i interviewed him for the russian
olympic
winter olympics and the putin's cronies
had built a road between sochi which is
on the coast
and the ski resort up in the mountains
and it cost five billion dollars
which was more than the um the mars
lander
nasa put on mars and it was so expensive
the valley said to me it would have been
cheaper to have paved the road
with louis vuitton handbags
he was from sochi born in sochi um
themselves and which is kind of like
russian brighton
and um lots of
gay bars so there's an issue
in that will gay olympians when they
come to compete will they
get persecuted because um the law in
russia is fabulously
and it is disgracefully um anti-gay
and i interviewed the putinous mayor of
sochi who says
it's not a problem in sochi because
there are no gays in sochi
and i put this to themselves and said
what i'm not sure that's the solution
there are no gays in sochi then why are
there so many gay bars
and actually it's a point i made to the
the mayor of sochi because well that's
funny because i went to a gay bar last
night
kind of deliberately anyway um
that was the kind of lovely humor that
nemtsov had
and then he shot dead 100 meters from
the kremlin
ah and um and of course
he's a big friend of navalny now
only knows this navalny knows to
challenge putin you may die
but you know he carries on
then the the kremlin bring a case of
embezzlement that he's
got a corrupt business with his brother
and what happens is his brother is put
inside the slammer
and he's held in horrible solitary
confinement
and all i've interviewed prisoners
who've been tortured
um cruelly in all sorts of awful places
algeria
uh syria the dark bits of africa
all sorts of ghastly places iraq the
worst thing is solitary confinement
where you don't talk to anybody
and they kept alexa's brother in
solitary confinement
he's still right now right no he's out
he's out he's out
so so part of the game he's out uh part
of the game
with putin is that putin affects
to be a democrat
um who follows the law but in reality
the system is rigged
uh it's a joke democracy it's a veiled
tyranny
a tyranny with gloves on the gloves are
fine they're made of the
the best goats leather but nevertheless
it's a tyranny and in particular angela
merkel
the west more feebly but angela merkel
who was brought up in east germany who
spoke russian as you had to as a little
girl
she speaks good russian and
she pushes putin on stuff and every now
and then putin
um sort of backs down when an angular
gets on the phone
says what are you doing about this so
anyway he got done for embezzlement i
think
part of the aspect of that trial ended
up him going to strasbourg
winning his case that's where i met him
in 2018.
so this is a constant background hum to
this
um now the other thing that happened was
that
he was you know he's let out and he
pushes
and he set up this wonderful clever
thing which is
basically the policy of the opposition
is to unite in opposition to putin's
party which he calls the party of
thieves and crooks
he his russian is really it's really
beautifully and powerfully expressed i'm
if people can remember um the plays of
dennis potter
where um one of the characters speaks so
beautifully that's kind of
the force you can hear the force of
navalny's rhetoric
he talks so beautifully and so
powerfully
um and
what you've got then is navalny never
stops
and he's a bit like a a duracell bunny
um and and there is i mean there is this
kind of monkish
belief in him but said against that
there is a sense of humor
so for example putin has made a policy
never to refer
to um navalny by name
because the blogger the vlogger doesn't
he
yeah the blogger and so i i said to when
i finally caught up with navalny
properly and interviewed him in moscow
in 2018.
i called him um so you know putin never
called you by name ah you mean lord
voldemort never calls me about my name i
like
i just wouldn't bang in this right but
it's funny i mean like
i would you know um we can't because of
lockdown
but if the three of us were in a pub
navalny would be fascinating his english
is
is good it's way i'll tell you my
favorite
the favorite thing that i found from him
so
he is doing a march somewhere or doing
one of his
parades one of his speeches and someone
comes up to him and throws green paint
in his face right
this happens twice first time it happens
it's green paint and the second time i
think it's green paint with acid in it
and he sat there and the doctor is
saying to him
miss navalny you may need to accept that
you
might not get eyesight back in this eye
and he's
recalling this tale in english to
someone in this interview i watched
today
he says so he said he tell me i may not
get my eye back so
what i think is is not so bad maybe i
become like a pirate you know i can wear
a patch
and i just thought [ __ ] me the same as
before this flight that he's just been
arrested getting off the other day
someone says to him
uh miss navalny like are you not worried
about being arrested and he says me
arrested no and you're like okay like
this guy this guy really understands
humor yes he's
um so i a worry over my russian friends
because of this dalliance with the far
right a decade ago
he ends up in some kind of some kind of
new putin figure
i don't think so because of something
i've observed as
people may know i fell out with the
church of scientology when i did a
panorama with them
and i got interested and fascinated by
cults there is a cult of personality in
putin
and there's a wonderful um professor
robert lifton those great american
military psychiatrists who first of all
treated american gis had been
brainwashed by the chinese communists
during the korean war
when they'd been caught in north korea
these are american gis who became
prisoners of the chinese communists and
they brainwashed them
and it's the origin he wrote a book
which became the origin
of um the manchurian candidate the novel
was based
on this guy's research and he said the
enemy of the authoritarian mind of the
cult
is tolerance of mockery and a sense of
humor
and and so i treasure
navalny's humor because it's proof to me
that he has got
inside his head somebody who's taking
the piss out of him
and he plays with that and it's also his
shield
as well and so i that's why i think
he won't become if he gets power uh he
won't become
another putin prove me wrong but
i think he's a sense of humor a sense of
of the ridiculous saves you
from believing from doing what i think
trump's ended up doing
you can't believe you're on [ __ ]
and if you do i mean it's a problem
because in power there are a lot of
people out to afflict you all the time
so you have to have some belief but to
have inside your
your sense of mission which he's got no
question
something that's that's mocking and
funny and
aware of irony then that's that's
that's a fantastic and beautiful safety
belt and he's got that in spades
so we roll the clock forward he's doing
these marches he's getting a lot of
young people to go along with him
and then he was poisoned last summer and
survived and then gets one of the
assassins to admit to the poisoning on
the telephone
and then posts it to his youtube channel
what's going on so what happens is
um so
the way russia works is none of this
could happen without putin
who's responsible i'm i'm going to take
you a little bit back
um too because we talked about the
blinding in the eye
because i met the group that did that
for this film i did
um called taking on putin
and i met these people and they went
along and after themselves who i knew
and admired very much was shot a local
people who lived in his
apartment block put up a a shrine to him
a little
a little um plaque and
there's a reef over it and they came
along and took the reef down
threw it away put it in the bin because
he actually lived in the next building
along but the owner of the next building
along wouldn't allow the plaque so it
was the nearest thing the locals
could find and these are anyway
what happens next is that um
that we are detained and sent to the
moscow
police station we're inside the moscow
police station when the kremlin media
said
that i had desecrated nemtsov shrine
our cameras and our tape can prove what
happened
um so this gives you a and
lo and behold stories um
about us appeared in the moscow media
and then my passport my cameraman's
passport
appeared on russian social media
and and we obviously given our passport
to the police
hello how did that happen it gives you a
flavor of them
so what we heard was that there and
um there's a wonderful uh couple
uh andre um that soldatov and his mrs
arena and they
they've written a fantastic book called
the compatriots blah blah blah
but he told me that the work here is
done by an organization called
center e which is the counter terrorism
police
but the group that um one of the members
of the group
threw the green dye with something like
acid it was the thing that
that scarred his eye we don't know what
it was exactly
but whatever that was was effectively
controlled
by group e barley the counter-terrorism
police
and they're the same people so what
happened to me was
after we got detained my passport was
um taken by these police officers and go
and bang up it goes on social media and
and i had to cancel the passport because
of that
you get some flavor what's happening
here is that putin's goons
are using administrative law to deny
that natural justice
again and again and again and the value
being a lawyer is fighting them
all the time all the time all the time
the poor man is blind in a
blinded he was going to lose his sight
and he makes a joke of it
so there's something about his courage
which is exceptional really exceptional
so last summer he
he's on a plane he's in um what he's
doing is he's going to the sticks
the way it works is that most people in
moscow and saint petersburg if there was
a free and fair election
would vote against putin they would vote
for navalny
the problem is in the sticks um
um you get people who can
who don't get the internet properly who
just watch state tv
who believe the nonsense that it's putin
or the devil
so he's going to the sticks
on a regular basis he was in tom
scoromsku i forget where
um and he's doing a thing what happens
is the goons get into his hotel room
and they put novichok which is the
poison that was used
in salisbury which killed dawn sturgis
meant to kill
um skripal and
almost killed a poor police officer in
salisbury
the same nerve agent and by the way you
cannot buy this in a shop
this is something that's made in a
poison factory
um and the wonderful people at
bellingham have
dug and found pretty pretty damning
evidence of where that poison fracture
will be
it's a state-owned poison factory
and what happened the next morning
um uh navalny put on a fresh pair of
blue underpants
we know this because i'll get there and
he's flying in the plane it's whatever
it is a five-hour flight
um from tom skoromsk to
moscow and suddenly he feels
violently ill screams in pain knocks out
the pilot heads the plane down he's
going to
save the guys and he saves the guy's
life and there's some nonsense about but
the airport being closed and the pilot
doesn't take it he lands the plane
the moment the plane lands the emergency
people jab him
with the stuff that you give for
somebody who's got some kind of
um i can give it to to to junkies
it's kind of standard first aid but it's
good
and actually work and exactly the same
effect happened in salisbury
so really quite quickly the immediate
people in russia did the right thing
the pilot and the emergency people
straight away then he's in the hospital
they keep him there for slightly too
long the point being for the
novichok to die away so they can't see
it and then he's flown to germany
in germany the best
doctors and scientists in germany find
the um find novichok
and then that's i think there are it's
tested
by other labs i think one is in uh
france ones in switzerland or something
like that so
three separate state level labs fine
nova chop poisoning the same
thing the same incredibly rare nerve
agent used in salisbury used against
navalny
navalny then um
gets in bed with bellingham which is
this wonderful organization of british
nerds
or it's led by a british nerd um
and it beautifully they they use
various holes and opennesses
inside the russian system to identify
everybody who was on that plane flying
with navalny to and from as he was on
his travels
around siberia and they see the same
names coming up again and again and
again and then they track them back
three years
and they un discover an assassin's creed
of the same fsb and then they find that
their fsb and they all work for the fsb
and some of them are connected to the
poison factory
then um they find their telephone
numbers
and they give this information to
navalny and the valley goes down the
list of like 20
possible people in the assassins crew
and on the last call he gets to some
goon
i said you know what hey it's uh and
then the valley is pretending
to be a a high up in the um and the
security people
and he said what went wrong and the guy
said well boss
everything went wrong and the guy talks
for about an hour
on tape to navalny explaining what
happened
i said so we put it on his underpants
and navalny didn't know that
because um and so what happened
beautifully i mean it was it it was like
chris it was like following a burglar's
footsteps
in the snow you know like guilty
guilty guilty now what i
what i would have done is to stop there
and and just waited until putin
goes but the valley knows that if he's
not in russia he's not
he's no longer a player he's just been
sidelined he's out of the game
so he sticks this out he flies back to
russia he's arrested and
bang he pops up the video which he's
been doing while he's in recuperation in
germany
of putin's latest palace it's an
extraordinary [ __ ] you
the guy is the guy the guy is super
rigorous
like you can't you can't fault the level
of precision that his
team is going through this so he had
this two hour
video done about a billion
pound palace of putin's with the hookah
and hooker bar in and
you're from the northeast uh it's a huka
bar
and um he's using this is the thing
right this is
i i've only looked into it this week
ahead of our episode today
and the sense that i get is he's kind of
like a sort of
a 21st century jokey trickster
using modern technology using drones and
youtubes against this sort of old
clunking behemoth
of the russian state and they're sort of
playing whack-a-mole
with this the sort of the old tools of
the old world
whereas navalny made this youtube video
about
the new mansion by fl by getting drones
and literally flying drones over the top
of 63 hectares of land
and then there's 3d cgi imagery
that shows you this is where the tunnel
goes this is where he can have his
coffee on a morning because this is
where the
the mezzanine level is that looks out
over the beach
like it really does feel like two worlds
kind of colliding do you get that sense
very much so and there's something
beautiful about it too because what this
is
is it is russia's cruel past
fighting russia's potentially
brilliant future now when i made the
film when i met the bell now i met some
of the people around him
and they're astonishingly brave and as i
said the three critics i spoke about
earlier
um um shot shot shot
these are uh nirvani supporters one man
was
tasered then stabbed another man was
uh beaten senseless beaten unconscious
by um
by thugs who never once said anything
that's special forces
when you beat somebody up you you say
[ __ ] you whatever you swear
you these people beat him up in total
silence what he was doing by the way was
monitoring
an election with a video what watching i
think either an election
or a demonstration from a video in real
time from the navalny people
and they they sourced them because it
was um
in real time they found him videoing and
then they
they beat him senseless um almost
until he was in a coma and they never
said a word
and then uh navalny's office manager
was hit over the head with an iron bar
by an assailant
and then um he put in the
um quite properly
he made a um a complaint
so that his um the man who attacked him
would be charged and he was accused of
wasting police
time now i've been there
in the i filmed
somebody taking a reef of nemtsov shrine
and then i was accused by her
and i and i suffered to a limited extent
i understand what's going on i
i am very moved by navalny's courage
and by the people who will support him
so this saturday
people will come out in the streets he's
asked them to do so
we're in the middle of a pandemic
russia's numbers
have been faked but they're bad
it's freezing cold and i'm going to be
fascinated to see how many people
turn up he's inside for 15 or 30 days
then he will be tried for
because they're saying he didn't comply
with the terms of his previous release
and therefore um
they can hit him with a long sentence
that's very likely
but the world has changed chris because
uh trump has gone and biden
is i think in no mood to
play mr nice with the man who he
believes
with evidence along with the cia
interfered
with america's democracy are you gonna
have
at this stage though this is something i
was thinking about increasingly
as i read this story and it reminded me
of the
i can't pronounce it yuga muslims in
china
like if we we go that's it sorry
if someone commits a crime against the
citizen of their own country
there's no one else to step in if the
state doesn't do it like america isn't
coming to the aid
of muslims in china and germany isn't
coming to help navalny
like is it realistic to expect that the
american president would say i don't
like how you're running your country
over there
even though it's not affecting your
relation with us
is that realistic to see that happening
well i think
the idea of a nation state can do
what it damn well pleases went out with
the holocaust
that went out with the nazis the the
virus is
you know underlines the point we live in
the same world
um so the rule of
law respect for life a fair trial
is um a right for all of us
not just people who live in the happy
and relatively happy
and safe and prosperous democracies and
navalny is pushing it now
i'm um i mean it's another conversation
for another day
about what's happening to the uyghurs
i've done a film about them
when i was the bbc um talking to a
a couple of people in um in istanbul
who managed to get out and that story is
grim
for the moment fingers crossed i hope
he's going to be okay
but navalny's story gives me tremendous
hope it's also
it's a kind of von stauffenberg thing
chris what's up
when people people say hey you know the
the germans they were all nazis no they
weren't
juan southenburg tried to blow up hitler
so he didn't succeed but he tried
and he got killed and all of his friends
were treated horribly
but they tried there were good germans
who tried to kill hitler
what's your prediction what do you think
happens you got 30 days
the next 30 days where he's potentially
back in russia he's in jail
he had this fake mock trial thing in the
police station
i think i mean all of that pantomime
will continue and it will be cruel
meanwhile ordinary and extraordinary
people in particular young people
the kind of people who are watching this
there
will come out on the streets and they'll
get beaten up and bashed and they might
lose their jobs and i think it's our
duty
to stand by them and to do something to
help them and now the valleys put out
is people have put out a thing they're
saying
we should have um the west should
um should act against some of the
oligarchs who've ended up
all concerned deny any any wrongdoing
but we've heard some of them
roman abramovich the guy owns chelsea
alicia usmanov
who was a part owner of arsenal who's
still still a big player in britain
um the the
navalny doesn't mention them but i will
um the lebedevs they own the evening
standard and the independent yevgeny
lebedev
has just been made a lord by boris
johnson
they're striking people because they you
know
you would appear it would appear that
they're they're independent they don't
do what the kremlin does
none of them have said a word about this
not a word
you have guinea lebedev lord lebron
siberia
has not said anything about it and he's
a british lawmaker is he beholden to a
foreign power
but essentially our bit what we should
do if i was in parliament if i was in
the house of lords lord sweeney of gin
and tonic right now would say this
that that we should um we should
that putin is there he's been there for
far too long
he has rigged our elections and he's
locked up the effective leader of the
opposition
his goons having poisoned him and his
goons having poisoned
dawn sturgis in salisbury let us
cut convertibility between the ruble
and the pound and the ruble and the
dollar that makes life
much more difficult for the rich people
in russia to run their lives
like they have because they don't want
to spend their money in siberia they
want to spend it in london
and in rome and in the south of france
but if you make that
much more difficult for them then the
calculation if you're a russian oligarch
my life is better with putin in charge
isn't
so clear and obvious so that's the the
leverage that needs to be used is to
make
the status quo which is being maintained
by
a careful structure of money and power
and enforcement
you need to make the world that
potentially could be offered
by navalny like genuine democracy more
attractive
than the current situation
with all of these restrictions in yeah
so what you say and um
there is a um there are sanctions on at
the moment
they're not really hurting and they're
not hurting the rich people
so you know you um you zap
the oligarchs wallets and their
calculation
putin is our man may change and that
that's that's something that we could do
and we should do and
that's what i'm arguing um here
or concerned deny any wrongdoing i mean
when i the last time i was in russia
when i came back my neighbors
said to me that now that was great john
but we're not going to accept any of
your amazon parcels anymore
i was going to say especially not if
it's a pair of blue pants
what's it going to take what's it going
to take for navalny to get into power
like is that there's no chance that
you're going to be able to with some 18
to 24 year olds
like tick-tocking in the street and
doing a few parades with some signs
there's no way that you're going to
knock down putin with that is there
as i said um towards the start
it's um the odds uh are against him but
but but my money is with the challenger
not with the poison toad
i think behind the 18 and 24 year olds
there's a whole bunch of middle-aged and
old people
who get it that he's been in power too
long who've seen
trump's in pound now trump's gone that's
the benefit of american democracy
it changes the tone will change they
will see
all sorts of stuff about biden who's
plainly a decent man
well why can't that happen in russia it
can't happen in russia
because russia never changes i don't
think
that is sustainable over time
so i think putin's in trouble he's on in
trouble number one because
oil and gas are boring and they're
damaging the planet the other day i
started listening
to david attenborough's um a life on
this planet
and it was so good and yet so depressing
he's pulling on some heart strings at
the moment man david every single time
he got like girls on instagram and he's
making everybody cry
and he's saying i don't have long left
for this world and he wants to try
i don't just think oh well i listened to
the man
and my part okay we don't need
russian oil and gas we actually don't
we're not flying
um the amount of i mean it's lovely to
see
um people on the other crazy scooters
i mean i used to see cars i don't see
cars outside my
uh my place in london i see people on
these scooters and bikes
we don't need russian oil and gas so
putin's got a problem in that he's
he's a is a political dinosaur sitting
on a dinosaur economy
still strong still massive still
frightening and cruel
but there are limits to it and there are
limits to the loyalty of his people but
we've got to work harder at doing that
but
the odds are against navalny but what he
is doing
is the idea that russia is a kind of
boring far-right um authoritarian stasis
where
no one is challenging the kremlin
that's not true inside russia
inside a police station inside a prison
right now
is the future of russia the the russian
soul
at its best the most interesting place
to be
right now is in prison with alexey
navalny
if i was russian i'm kind of i can't
because of lockdown but if i could
i'd fly straight out there get into a
fight get locked up
and and i'll have a chat with you next
door yeah what a pleasure and
say hello i mean it's been quite a while
but
here's your first inside journal
interview and somebody would smuggle it
out
because remember even the palace stuff
the hooker room set again in your funny
northeast accent
[Laughter]
in the hookah room there is somebody
who's given that to navalny
so that so the the and that is the thing
about russia
is that it's got it's got proper soul
there is a proper sense of the people
in around him that this is
a war they're fighting and it's a war
where truth and justice and the law
is on their side and the people in power
are rigging the thing again and again
and again
and what the value is doing is proving
that
in a way which is it's kind of beautiful
i want everybody who's listening to this
nonsense
it's not nonsense to watch the the
novelly video
because we linked it'll be linked in the
show notes below can you just give us
the
what's the cliff notes on
this new mansion video and why is it
important
it's disgusting it's disgusting but is
that is it is the is the issue that
he president lord of russia vladimir
putin has no class and style is that the
issue
or is it the issue that he's spent so
much money is it where it is what's
going on
uh the primary issue
is everybody is suffering
because of the because of the virus also
in russia too
um and for him to squander
a billion pounds on this absurd palace
when he's got plenty of other palaces
um beautiful ones um historical ones
he doesn't need this he doesn't need
this at all
and yet he squandered this money and
that is the fruit of his corruption
and that is a criminal waste of money
so what it shows is that
is that vladimir putin is the al capone
of russia
he's the gambino crime family and he has
his family got richer and richer of
russia
he is the ronnie and reggie cray russia
two ghastly twins in one unwholesome
poison-toed body i
i mean another thing i haven't talked
about but i will
um i did a report for panorama
about mh17 this was the plane that was
shot down
by a russian um rocket launcher
lent to the pro-russian ukrainian rebels
and they thought it was the ukrainian
fighter jet but they shot it down and
298 people died and i went out there
for panorama and we and i
did a piece of camera and the dyeing of
the light
surrounded by um
engine oil and broken engines and broken
planes
and the nose and other people's luggage
and the worst thing is chris is the
those little
um things that kids the little mini
suitcases with little wheels
that a toddler sits on or mum and dad
run them along and they were in the
fields
the airplane oil burnt fields
of of the middle of nowhere in ukraine
and whenever i go through gatwick or
heathrow and i
see one of those and i start welling up
i start to cry because it triggers that
10 britons died in that a ton of
australians lots of dutch people
malaysian people
298 people and the person
ultimately responsible with that because
you cannot buy a rocket launcher in a
shop
with vladimir putin and he got away with
that
um dawn sturgis died
of novichok in salisbury it feels like
putin's got away with that
and and you know there's a certain point
in which
we've got to stand up to this man and
also
we should help this beautiful brave
slightly crazy guy called alexei navalny
watches stuff
writes your mp push it
what is your opinion or what is your
estimate
for the next 10 years in russia
where do you think it's heading i know
where you want it to head
but given the the realism and the power
and the money and the state and all that
stuff
what do you think is going to happen
right so most likely um
navalny there's some accident
happens to him in prison one of the
other psychos kills him
there's a trial
putin stays in power how old is putin
now he can't stay in power for that much
longer
he he's um he's seven he can stay in
power for as long as he bloody wants
well as long as he's alive yeah um
but that's the thing if if so that's the
most likely
what i'm hoping for what i want to
happen
is that that the soul of russia
wakes from its slumber sparked
by alexey navalny's heroism
people get out in the streets and at the
same time
joe biden who's seen his country defiled
by donald trump but also in part
by russian interference in american
democracy
does stuff um i'm
skeptical whether boris johnson would do
anything he's the man who's a
a noble one of vladimir putin's only
oligarchs i feel that
i but i feel that change is in the air
and and as i said at the beginning
my money is on
the challenger not the
poison toad it's i said this about my
about uh julen maxwell
that story that was a dark fairy story
and this is two
but i'm i it is a dark
story and you've got the you've got the
charismatic guy who's gone into the
lion's den he's gone back into prison
knowing he's going into prison
and it it's kind of like
um
steve mcqueen in um uh
and the great escape that he's sitting
in the cooler
but boy boy you know if you've got a
heart and soul
whose side are you on you've got to be
on the side of the prisoner there's one
more thing is that
in 88 as a young reporter for the
observer i went to south africa
when mandela was still in prison and i
got you know
gasped by the um south african apartheid
police apartheid was still
in power but you could tell that they
were more afraid of the prisoner
but the somehow the politics the the
the shape of power had been switched
so the prisoner was more trouble in
prison
and they were they were finding a way of
getting him out
now that the problem is that putin
it's different but if putin has a stroke
or putin drinks the wrong cup of tea
then who knows what happens so once
again
my money is on the challenger not the
poison toad
anyone that can deliver 26 million
youtube views in the space of 24 hours
shouldn't be messed with
absolutely not that's dangerous man i
mean it's it's i was looking at i did a
little bit of crunching on the stats on
the back end
his youtube channels had a quarter of a
million subscribers
added in a day it's absolutely
terrifying and then
when you look at the total plays across
his channel the trickle down from people
finding that one video which is probably
trending across russia and
eastern europe uh has trickled into
everything else as well
so i mean if there's any aspiring
youtubers listening and you want to go
and look at some
ridiculous stats just go on socialblade
and search for
uh navalny's account because it's
absolutely terrifying
but i this is the most interesting time
i can't imagine what it's like
to be inside of i mean i can't imagine
what it's like to be inside of putin's
head
most of the time but i certainly can't
imagine what it's like now
when you have this
this new weaponry rhetoric
and and um charisma that's being
uh utilized and promulgated through a
channel which you don't
use and you're fighting with sticks and
clubs and this person's coming with like
a laser sword
and has decided to use that it very much
does feel like
david and goliath old against new
there's definitely some archetypes going
on which i think is what makes it so
interesting
what i found fascinating and you may
have noticed this if you watched one of
navalny's videos is that he's got some
hard-coded adverts part way through and
this it's this
young guy who hosts the channel and he's
letting him speak same way as we've been
tonight
and he goes but first like a word from
our sponsor and it cuts to him talking
about the sponsor
the first thing he says is 50
of people aged between 18 and 24 in
russia
say that they want to leave to go and
work somewhere else
and his campaign is don't leave you
don't need to leave russia
you can work for these cut these
different countries companies
from within russia but you need to learn
english and i learned english with this
particular company
50 of the population
aged between 18 and 24
don't want to be in that country anymore
like that the fact that you have that
in it you don't think of russia i know
that there's jokes made about it being a
dictatorship
but you don't think of russia in the
same league as north korea but when you
think that
half of the people who are probably the
the most up-to-date
the most informed about what's going on
and also have sufficient time left to be
able to make a choice
given the freedom without the
restrictions of family and debt and all
the rest of it
and they don't want to be there anymore
that's pretty terrifying
yes well i'm but it's a logical
consequence
and the number doesn't surprise me that
if you
um want to um
if you apply for a permit to do
something you have to pay somebody off
again and again and again if
if you annoy somebody in power or you
know
like you've got a relationship and then
um you're in love with somebody but then
somebody else
um who's in power who's a policeman or
or worse
an fsb officer fancies your woman
then you could get you get locked up you
could get into trouble
because of this but those are real world
things there
so crazy it's a dark
dark place now no i've been to north
korea um
and and but you know
i'm telling you the truth when i got to
beijing i thought thank god
i'm just in the same way
there were people with pink hair i
thought thank god i
um only slightly fascist china as
opposed to that place
because by the way left and right in
places like north korea
and china and russia they they kind of
fuse
but but actually um these days
russia is is way it was under stalin
the story of i try and tell my my
thriller the useful idiot
is that stalin's russia was close
to nazi germany long before the
the midnight pact of 39 they were doing
deals
the nazis um and the nazi sympathizers
and the soviet states from 31 onwards
so and and also
remember that the russian state has been
funding the far right it
it helped it helped trump get elected
it's been helping the far right in
britain and across europe
um that is what the kremlin is doing
that's where the money's doing
so in part what we should be doing in
helping naval at least watching his
videos and becoming
centrevised to his to his heroism is
also we're trying to defend our common
democratic values
which is that's a universal thing the
other thing i'd say to you
um everybody who's watching when we can
travel again is go to russia
go to by the way go via belarus
um take a copy of a 1984
animal farm leave it in a bar um
go you know if you can if the van is
still
doing it um i hope he is go on a demo
um if you're um
if your family's got money and your
dad's got access to fancy lawyers
get arrested it sounds like it sounds
like a wonderful holiday i'm actually
going to
ukraine levov and then going saint
petersburg
and moscow this summer with my friend
michael mallis
who is a podcaster and a media
personality in his own right
but he's born in born in levov and
he's going going back to his homeland
for the first time ever i'm going with
him we're going to do a full video
series
it's fantastic weirdly um
because i lost my temper the church of
scientology and i did this
panorama rubbishing scientology
i'm a pin-up for psychiatrists the world
over
and when there was a um
the royal college of psychiatry through
an international symposium for
psychiatrists
um i was the the funny man before the
drinks at the excel center and i got
5000 psychiatrists to dance to
saturday night fever with john travolta
who is of course a famous
scientologist and i got the the then
head of the royal college of psychiatry
for simon wesley
to pretend to be john travolta and dance
and he's a terrible anyway never mind
this
what happens is as a result of that i
got an invite
to give a talk at the ukrainian
college of psychiatry in the wolf and
and they flew me out there and it's a
wonderful place
formerly also hungarian then um
then then soviet but was always the
center of
resistance the soviet group think and
it's a fantastic place but so is russia
i mean it is an incredible thing that
gets my goat is that when i'm accused of
being russophobic
i love russia i love russian culture
russian books russian poetry
there's a wonderful phrase uh by the
month of the restless he begs for storms
as though in
storms there is rest incredibly
beautiful culture
fantastic alcohol vodka
freezing cold in the snow you won't get
that but you can anyway
it you'll have the time of your life
i'll ask you i'll ask you for some
recommendations john you can send me
some of the
but but chris if there is if you don't
go to navalny
demonstration and don't get arrested
then i'm on your case
okay fair enough well that looks that
looks like it's going to be look ma'am
we're going to do
um we're going to do a round two i'm
going to get you back on to talk
about one of my favorite podcasts from
last year which was your hunting july
series
if anyone wants to go and learn about
the julian maxwell
scandal and where everything's up to now
and that's a really interesting arc as
well which we're going to get into on
the next one but i
implore everyone to go and have a listen
to that also
useful idiot and the usual i've done an
audio book as well
and there's a twist i have to do a bit
of welsh in it
okay my mispronunciation of the welsh
is you have to listen to it to get it
you're just
just causing bother with every different
country that you can find aren't you
where else should people check out your
stuff why do you want to direct them
so i'm on twitter um i don't use
facebook but i'm on twitter
at john sweeney raw r o a r
and i've got a website um
johnsweeny.co.uk and i'm on amazon i've
written 12 books
some of them are good some of them are a
bit rubbish frankly but uh
you can work that out amazing john thank
you so much for today
you